devrait-on privilégier les œufs enrichis
ou on fait un compromis sur la valeur
nutritive lorsqu'on choisit le bon
vieille oeuf blanc de taille moyenne on
a évalué les options qui s'offrent à
nous
au plat en omelette dure ou à la coque
quand on parle d'eux il y en a pour tous
les goûts mais avant de terminer dans
notre assiette le feuille droit à tout
un traitement
[Musique]
et si on passe environ 2.5 à 3 millions
d'heures par jour les fermes burn Drey
et nutrief sont les deux grands
classificateurs deux au Québec entre la
ferme et l'épicerie c'est dans leurs
usines que les œufs sont classifiés
la classification c'est une fois qu'on a
reçu les œufs des producteurs on doit
les laver on doit les peser et on doit
les emballer
les œufs sont
mises les œufs sont séchés et il se
dirigent vers la table de miracle
on a une grosse lumière puis on peut
voir à l'intérieur d'un œuf et on retire
s'il y a des imperfections s'il y a du
sens il y a des cracks et après le
mirage on pèse les œufs donc les œufs
sont classés en fonction du poids et
puis à partir de là l'ordinateur envoie
les œufs selon les formats dans les
bonnes lignes d'emballage
une fois que les œufs sont dans la
douzaine sont mis dans les caisses et
puis on est prêt à partir pour les
épices
et pourquoi il y a tant de grossières
tant de taille sur les tablettes des
épiceries dans son cycle de vie la peau
la vapote des petits œufs ensuite des
moyens puis des gros et des extra gros
vers la fin de son site de pompe l'âge
de la poule détermine donc la taille de
l'oeuf le format en partant qui se vend
le plus c'est les gros et puis c'est
encore les produits de commodité donc le
blanc régulier qui se trouve à être dans
les meilleurs vendeurs
depuis plusieurs années pourtant toute
une gamme 2 de spécialités se sont
taillées une place sur les tablettes
d'épicerie il en existe deux catégories
la première le fa valeur ajoutée
principalement en oméga 3
est-ce que c'est un peu une illusion de
marketing où il y a vraiment une valeur
oui il y a vraiment une valeur ajoutée
c'est la nourriture qu'on donne aux
pôles pour que la quantité d'Oméga ou de
vitamines qui est ciblée soit présente
en quantité suffisante pour qu'on puisse
le déclarer comme étant un ajout la peau
la laisse facilité là de transmettre ce
qu'elle mange à l'intérieur de son œuvre
la deuxième catégorie 2 de spécialités
met de l'avant le bien-être animal
c’est-à-dire le logement de la poule il
en existe plusieurs variétés on a le
logement traditionnel alors qui est en
face d'être éliminé alors c'est la cage
traditionnelle l'espace relativement
limité on parle d'environ là une feuille
par 11 là ça c'est l'espace à louer à
une poule et sont peut-être de 8 à 12
dans un endroit comme ça
des cages traditionnelles encore
tolérées mais plus pour longtemps
elle est en face d'élimination donc
toute nouvelle installation ne peut pas
être en cash traditionnel et au rythme
où vont les choses font certains
qu'autour de 2030 il y aurait plus de
pôle en cash traditionnels au Canada
plusieurs types de logements peuvent
remplacer les caches traditionnelles
dont le logement enrichi c'est une cage
avec plus d'espace et il y a un endroit
pour aller pondre il y a un perchoir il
y a un grattoir il y a beaucoup plus
d'espace par animal aussi par Paul
on définit bien être animal comme étant
la possibilité pour l'animal justement
de d'exprimer ses comportements naturels
puisqu'on appelle le logement enrichi
serait la meilleure alternative pour les
poules la tendance semble pourtant à
aller vers un autre type de logement les
poules ont liberté mais attention en
liberté ne veut pas nécessairement dire
en extérieur en liberté il y a
différents modèles
en voilière ou là les poules doivent
voler ou prendre un escalier pour se
rendre là où il y a la nourriture ou
encore l'eau elle doit fondre leur œuf
dans un poulailler on peut peut-être
avoir 10 12000 poules qui sont en
liberté tout en même temps et on peut
avoir en liberté avec un accès à
l'extérieur et souvent au Québec ça va
se traduire par les œufs bio
des œufs bio de plus en plus populaires
il y a de plus en plus de productions
et je pense que dans les dernières
années il y a une prise de conscience il
y a des gens de plus en plus sensibles à
ça les gens s'intéressent de plus en
plus à savoir d'où ça vient et comment
s'est produit mais ces œufs de
spécialité ont un prix de 6 à 7 dollars
pour une douzaine d’œufs avec oméga 3 et
de 8 à 9 pour la même quantité de
biologique quant aux yeux réguliers le
prix moyen la douzaine se vend autour de
3 dollars 90
blanc brun biologique avec oméga 3 qu'en
est-il d'un point de vue nutritionnel
un blanc on a l'impression que les bruns
c'est plus santé est-ce que c'est une
perception les yeux bruns les yeux
blancs c'est pas comme le ping brun et
le pain blanc valeur nutritive c'est la
même chose c'est tout simplement la race
de la poule donc les poules brunes
pondent des yeux bruns tout simplement
et les œufs bio les œufs biologiques on
a deux éléments positifs donc non
seulement les poules vont avoir été bien
traités mais aussi leur alimentation va
provenir d'aliments biologique donc oui
on peut aller choisir ces deux-là par
contre sont très très dispendieux et les
oméga 3 les œufs de poules en Chine
oméga 3 il va y avoir effectivement plus
d'oméga 3 dans les œufs à quantité égale
pour à peu près 100 g de saumon on a
presque 3 fois plus d'oméga 3
compatiblement à deux œufs si on a
besoin d'un petit plus puis que on est
végétarien par exemple on consomme pas
de poisson mais d'aller chercher des
œufs qui ont ce petit plus là ça peut
valoir la peine est-ce qu'on fait un
compromis sur la valeur nutritive
lorsqu'on achète le bon vieille oeuf
blanc de taille moyenne un œuf ça
contient plein de nutriments donc que ce
soit un œuf archi d'oméga 3 ou depuis la
liberté même un œuf traditionnel ça
contient quand même de la vitamine A de
la vitamine D de la vitamine E c'est une
excellente source de protéines aussi qui
est accessible
quand même un impact positif à choisir
des œufs de pôle en liberté biologique
oméga 3 c'est des œufs qui ont un petit
plus mais ça veut pas dire que les
autres offres ne valent plus rien et si
vous cherchez des œufs au meilleur prix
les promotions ne sont pas toujours la
meilleure option souvent on va se
retourner vers les yeux en spécial on va
voir les étiquettes jaunes rouges à
l'épicerie mais ce qui est de plus
important de regarder c'est le coup
unitaire alors le format de 39 les gens
pourront le constater à l'épicerie c'est
souvent le format ou le couponitaire de
l'oeuf et le moins cher
enfin si vous doutez de la fraîcheur de
vos yeux voici un petit truc un œuf qui
est plus frais quand on voit le casser
le blanc va se tenir tandis qu'un œuf
qui est moins frais le blanc va
s'éteindre donc si on peut se faire des
petits œufs pochés on veut qu'il soit
beau on prend un œuf qui est plus frais